franchement madame un jour la télé ses
stars à la maison c'est vous qui avez
été tiré au sort ah non je veux laisser
rentrer
t
le tableau là on peut l'enlever ou pas
ouais ouais
je sais vraiment pas où
je pouvais pas quelque chose volontiers
oui
je sais pas vous avez de la bière ah oui
bien sûr oui bah bien d'accord cas pas
de problème je vais chercher ça c'est
gentil
merci merci merci
mais pas cheap alors oui
on est bien
je mets mes pieds mais bon non mais j'ai
mal aux pieds souffrez vous montrer la
chambre
verra pourquoi
c'est le bordel ouais je voulais c'est
10 minutes à franchimont dire ça parce
que seront abordés d'accord
[Musique]
non on
peut passer à côté des choses simples un
accord donc le bain ac je nettoyais
parce qu'il n'est pas le cul là vous
avez
excusez moi
faudrait couper le téléphone ce soir
qu'on soit pas emmerdé 1-1 madame
way
moi je dors une heure ou deux pour aller
faire les courses
la seule chose c'est que je retourne à
6h chercher ma fille à l'école ouais
quoi les ignares de la maison il bosse
je change les droits aussi tout à
l'heure pardon il faut que je change
nettement oui mais comme je veux faire
l'amour avec la petite l'a donc ouvriers
change pas après
laissez moi s'il vous plaît laissez moi
[Musique]